in the far reaches of Papua New Guinea
the Caron tribesmen hunt a delectable
dish it has fur fangs and claws and it's
not something most Westerners with dare
to taste it's a bat the flying fox bath
to be precise
Samuel district loves its tasty meat
flying fox a couple of times a month we
eat it to Westerners bats are the stuff
of nightmares and horror movies just say
that and many think of vampires sinking
their fangs and two helpless victims
even in the real world bats are thought
of as carriers of dreaded diseases like
rabies but in the madonna region of
Papua New Guinea
the Caron people have a long tradition
of hunting bats as food the flying fox
is the most common breed of that here
it's also the largest bat in the world
that means bigger claws bigger teeth and
bigger wings these fruit eaters can
weigh up to three and a half pounds 50
times as much as the average bat
the flying fox bats aren't easy to catch
but for these car and men it is a
tradition they have been raised from
boyhood to use ingenuity and homemade
weapons to nab them today they'll mount
a sneak attack through the thick
overgrowth and come at the bats from
behind the flying fox bats wait
unsuspectingly with their beady eyes and
large wings the men will have to wade
into the lake but there's one problem
these waters are teeming with deadly
crocodiles
we've got one set we went into the trees
do I hit them while they were hanging
they fell down and we caught them they
fell into the water and we got them and
put them in the canoe back at the
village fresh coconuts are cut up for
the main dish
the hunters steered clear of the
crocodiles and brought home plenty of
bats now I'm sending the hair on the
flying fox path the bat is roasted until
the fur is gone
then cut up into pieces and lightly
boiled
much of the meat remains raw this
creature has fangs claws and leathery
wings which would make it highly
unappetizing to most Outsiders but these
men's mouths are watering as an
appetizer the chefs also roast sago
grubs a little green garnish completes
the dish as the ones who brought it back
to the village the hunters will eat
first
they eat the bat bones as well as the
meat and how does raw bat meat taste it
tastes like chicken same kind of flavor
it tastes good other places don't eat
them we don't know about their food
traditions we eat them because our
ancestors did and so will our children
and grandchildren
[Music]